what do you think it was about the
eighties about that time between the
wrestling thing in the movies you did
what was so cool about the eighties that
so many people obviously myself included
have such like great nostalgia poor for
that time
well the rate it but what happened was
wrestling with national all of a sudden
nearly
you had been 26 regionalized territories
it had come out at the carnival world it
had gone into the 26 region wise
territories
and all these promoters 26 I'm really
were kinda like the Mafia
nobody ever cross their linings I
men in the eighties came young Vince
McMahon junior Astana
Vince McMahon senior what he did all
nobody any allegiance
and he had a vision and along with that
came cable television
he started buying up cable TV and he
took
wrestling national and he took it to
levels we never
I'll never forget the night we did NBC
the first night
NBC's Saturday Night mean about I
remember it we altered
where we alternated every three to four
weeks were Saturday Night Live
and the greatest one ever was the second
season
they had madonna I opening up Saturday
Night Live she was red-hot
we came on three weeks later in blue her
numbers right out of the water
to this day rash laying shattered
tonight mean about
has the highest ratings for what they
call the weekend special
we actually did what was it up 34% share
well I mean what you know we always
think about the Golden Age it will be
and and but that really was the golden
age arresting although it seems to be a
pretty nice comeback
my final question for you I'm gonna Andy
on a big one who's running the show
who is running the show i I know your
conspiracy guy I know you know a lot
about everything
who really at the end of the day is
right is
is this the government is this the only
woman now D who is it running the show
you know I can't ship date even tell you
I didn't tell you who's doing it and I
used to not believe a matter luma na
Bibi used to not believe in
world government would be rather but I'm
somewhat change my mind now in the
investigation drive down in the things
I've watched a machine and I'm 62 years
old now
it seems to me mighty strange I don't
believe
that our president runs our country
anymore because the classic example was
Brock Obama when he ran now
he said he would call was get mall he
said he would do all be strange
a memo many gotten off fresh most things
we're all for gotten
our foreign policy there's no difference
in our foreign policy
between george bush and Barack Obama at
all
none whatsoever im show somebody else in
to me it's gotta be the powerful money
people it's got to be the Federal
Reserve in the bankers
who control the money because if you
control the money
you control everything